and now more on the swamp versus Donald
Trump with developments today at the DC
circuit on Trump's appeal of his gag
order now this was a two-hour hearing
the three judge panel hinted that it
would affirm that gag order issued by
Judge Amy chiten but that they also May
limit the reach of the order with one
judge saying this I'm not shutting down
everyone who speaks is only affecting
speech temporarily during a criminal
trial process by someone who has been
indicted as a fell no one here is
threatening the First Amendment
broadly joining me now David Shon former
Trump impeachment attorney and Saul
weisenberg former deputy independent
Council Fox News contributor now Doug I
know you've argued cases before a few of
these federal appell court judges they
seem skeptical about Trump's core
political speech argument that judge
Mallette was referencing there yeah they
seem skeptical about that on the other
hand they recognize that this order has
got to be narrowed they have vague terms
in it like targeting targeting a witness
and so on to give you an example of how
vague and unenforceable that term is and
by the way and as you well know in the
Free Speech area when a term is vague it
chills speech automatically because an
actor doesn't know when or he when when
he or she can speak judge chken herself
when given an example by Jack Smith the
special counsel uh cited that example
and said well that almost certainly
violates the targeting provision if she
doesn't know what violates it how can a
criminal defendant then risk
real serious consequences um under such
an order so I think the order is going
to be narrowed I'm not in favor of any
gag order it's a prior restraint um the
court has dealt with this before in
nebras Nebraska press it doesn't meet
the criteria there for issuing a gag
order this is a defendant remember not a
lawyer the DC court has very stringent
rules under rule 57.7 a local rule on
what a lawyer can say a criminal
defendant is a an innocent citizen as a
matter of Law and I like to look at it
as his or her first and sixth amendment
rights right to free speech right to a
public trial has to be measured by the
Fifth Amendment right which is the
presumption of
innocence well Saul to this point now
the panel may end up allowing Trump to
continue to criticize uh the special
counsel Jack Smith but it would keep the
ban in place for Witnesses and Court
staff um explain
that well listen I listened to almost
all of the argument Laura and this order
is not going to stand in its current
form it is going to be significantly
narrow two things really striking that
stood out today number one the example
that everybody is horrified by uh is
Trump's statement about General Millie
that his his actions were treasonous
after the election and that in the past
that would be punishable by death they
pretty much made it it clear that that
is pure protected speech and they
pointed out that Trump's statement was
in response to a TV appearance by Millie
the previous day where he was Hawking
his book I found that very significant
also significant at another Point uh is
that the government made a very
important concession they actually said
that he can that Trump can name the
prosecutors the prosecutor Jack Smith by
name that goes beyond judge chuckin
order I thought that was very
significant and they said he can do it
as long as he's he does it at a high
level of generality and then the court
said wait a minute that's that's classic
vague speech isn't it why can't he name
Smith by name and why can't he name the
individuals who are on Smith's staff so
I found those to be very significant
things this is going to be narrowed
significantly now David they're trying
to justify the gag order any way they
can here watch
this they are arguing this as if they're
talking about a statute passed by
Congress to restrict the speech of a
candidate and that's not what this is at
all this is an order to restrict the
speech of a defendant in a high-profile
criminal case and the judge has a duty
to protect the Integrity of the
case David the Integrity of the process
when the president of former president
of the United States is part of his
campaign is the corruption in our legal
system that I mean this is takes on a
whole new level does it not absolutely
first of all it's a matter of great
public interest if president Trump
thinks that the process stinks and has
no Integrity he's entitled to say it
like any other American is entitled to
say it call it like it is but the and
the court by the way was aware it got
short shrift today but they were aware
of the campaign and they said how's he
going to be able to respond to attacks
on him based on the indictment when he
can't if he's not permitted to speak
about the process the hypocrisy
surrounding this is unbelievable if
you're concerned about tainting a jury
pool how about this judge judge Chin's
previous statements in other cases
holding president Trump responsible for
January 6th before he's ever been tried
how about the speaking indictment 45
pages by the government of unproven
allegations that anyone can download and
have in front of them every day just
last Friday judge chuin denied a defense
motion to strike inflammatory
allegations from the indictment saying
well we can deal with any kind of
prejudice from this kind of publicity
through Vere why is it when the
government says something it can be
addressed through Vere but if the
defendant president Trump wants to say
something it should be barred yeah and
sa then in that Colorado case the judge
there on the other CA the other issue of
trying to pull him from the ballot a
separate case obviously on 14th
Amendment grounds in Colorado the judge
there ruled that Trump they made a
factual finding saying that Trump is
responsible for inciting an Insurrection
but he can remain on the ballot well the
left went crazy with that all day long
saying that was you know that was
fantastic because it sets a factual
predicate in Colorado is that
significant
today I I don't think it's significant
the significant thing in that in that
opinion was that she held back she
realizes that the his iCal record uh is
is very mixed on this so she exercised
judicial restraint you can tell it
killed her but what some judge in
Colorado thinks about Insurrection I
don't think is going to have any effect
on any of the federal cases here all
right well well if they if they take it
to the Supreme Court I think they wanted
to establish that factual predicate but
who knows what will happen but David and
sa you'll be with us all the way thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else